Andy's grandfather ran the business. Then his father ran the business. They make mousetraps, Victor brand mousetraps with the big red V on them. But also glue traps, and electric traps, and those humane catch and release things. And traps that only professionals use. Andy's in charge of the part of the company that develops the new products and the job suits him. I called him in his office.
安迪的祖父经营着这家公司，后来由他父亲接手。他们生产捕鼠器，就是那种印着大红色V字的维克多（Victor）牌捕鼠器。但他们也生产粘鼠板、电子捕鼠器，以及那些人道的活捉释放装置，还有只有专业人士才会使用的捕鼠器。安迪负责公司的新产品开发部门，这份工作很适合他。我给他的办公室打了电话。
I remember coming out here on Saturdays when I was very young and seeing the mousetraps being made and just being intrigued by the business.
我记得我很小的时候，周六会到这里来，看着捕鼠器被制造出来，对这门生意感到非常好奇。
So I understand that because you guys are the number one mousetrap company in the world, people pitch you ideas on how to make a better mousetrap, right?
我了解，因为你们是全球第一大捕鼠器公司，所以肯定有人向你们推销如何制造“更好的捕鼠器”，对吧？
All the time.
一直都有。
Can I ask you to just talk about some ones that were especially bad?
能请你谈谈其中一些特别糟糕的例子吗？
Oh my. One that we rejected was one that is basically a pail that, in essence, the mouse can run up the side of. Up a stairway, and then between one side of the bucket and the other, there's a dowel. And in the middle of it, a little cup of bait. So they run across the dowel, and once they get to the cup, it turns over and spills them--
天哪。我们拒绝过一个方案，那基本上是个桶，老鼠可以顺着桶壁爬上去，沿着台阶走，然后桶的两侧之间有一根木棍。木棍中间放着一个小饵杯。老鼠跑过木棍，一旦到达饵杯，它就会翻转，把老鼠倒进……
Into the bucket.
倒进桶里。
Into a pail of-- and since they wanted to be environmentally friendly, a pail of antifreeze that was environmentally friendly.
倒进一个装着——因为他们想做到环保，所以是一个环保型防冻液的桶里。
Wait, wait.
等等，等等。
Right, and I believe that the antifreeze would also keep the scent problem down of a dead rodent. You might have a whole 20 drowned mice in this thing. And so it's incredibly ingenious and very clever.
没错，而且我相信防冻液还能抑制死老鼠带来的气味问题。这玩意儿里可能会淹死整整20只老鼠。所以它非常有创意，非常聪明。
So do you think that actually could work?
那你觉得这真的行得通吗？
Oh it does work.
哦，它确实行得通。
It does work, but it's not the sort of thing that you think many people are going to want to buy?
它确实行得通，但你认为会有多少人想买这种东西呢？
Right, people really don't want a pail, to end up with a-- I mean having a dead mouse for a lot of people is a problem. Having a dead mouse in a pail of antifreeze and dumping it out, or in this case having maybe six or seven, just is not commercially, in our opinion, a great opportunity.
确实，人们真的不想用一个桶，最后还要处理……我的意思是，对很多人来说，处理死老鼠是个问题。桶里装着死老鼠和防冻液，还要把它倒掉，或者像这种情况，桶里可能装着六七只，在我们看来，这在商业上算不上什么好机会。
I mean people are incredibly creative. I mean I've got a book of patents that were just from the late 80's to 1950. And there are thousands and thousands of tanks and cages, all sorts of weird looking shaped boxes and things that look like medieval torture chambers.
我的意思是，人们非常有创造力。我有一本专利书，里面全是80年代末到1950年之间的专利。有成千上万种水箱、笼子，各种奇形怪状的盒子，看起来就像中世纪的刑具。
Can you tell me one where you totally admired the ingenuity, but you just thought, no way.
你能讲一个你非常佩服其独创性，但觉得绝对行不通的例子吗？
Well, yeah I sure will. This one is alarming in its ingenuity. A mouse went into a little box area, and when it nibbled at the bait, the door shut behind it. OK, nothing too abnormal about that. But it dropped a pill into a little bit of water. And the pellet dropped into water and it gave off a gas the killed them. And it would die of carbon monoxide poisoning. In other words, it went into a gas chamber.
嗯，当然可以。有一个方案其独创性令人震惊。老鼠走进一个小盒子区域，当它啃食诱饵时，身后的门就会关上。好吧，这没什么特别的。但它会往一点点水里掉一颗药丸。药丸落入水中会释放出一种气体，将老鼠杀死。它会死于一氧化碳中毒。换句话说，它走进了一个毒气室。
And was this ever sold anywhere?
这东西在什么地方卖过吗？
In Germany.
在德国。
Oh come on.
别开玩笑了。
I am not kidding.
我没开玩笑。
I'm sitting here literally stunned. As as a Jewish person, I actually am stunned.
我坐在这里简直惊呆了。作为一名犹太人，我确实感到震惊。
I was horrified. We didn't think that had very good commercial liability in the United States. And we were surprised that it was available, that people were trying to market it in Germany.
我当时感到毛骨悚然。我们认为这在美国没有很好的商业责任，而且我们很惊讶它竟然能上市，竟然有人在德国试图推广它。
So with all of these people trying to invent a better mousetrap, the dirty secret of trapping mice is, mice are really easy to catch. That's why every inventor thinks that he can do it. Catching a mouse is basically playing against a casino where you always win. The regular, old-fashioned, cheap little mousetrap, Andy says, will usually catch the mouse in 24 to 48 hours. It will kill it 88% of the time. Other traps that aren't much more expensive have 100% lethality. Mice are easy to kill because mice, unlike rats, are incredibly inquisitive animals.
所以，尽管有这么多人试图发明更好的捕鼠器，但捕鼠业一个肮脏的秘密就是，老鼠其实很容易捕捉。这就是为什么每个发明家都觉得他能做到。抓老鼠基本上就像在赌场里博弈，而且你永远是赢家。安迪说，那种廉价的老式捕鼠器通常能在24到48小时内抓住老鼠。它的致死率高达88%。其他并不贵多少的捕鼠器甚至有100%的致死率。老鼠很容易被杀，因为老鼠不像大鼠，它们是极其好奇的动物。
They investigate anything that's new. Anything that's in their normal territory for the evening, and that's typically-- most people don't know this but most mice only stay within 10 feet of where they are, max. And oftentimes it's less than that. And they may investigate that area 30 times during the night. They're not just going out once.
它们会调查任何新的东西。任何出现在它们当晚活动范围内的东西，而且通常——大多数人不知道这一点，但大多数老鼠的活动范围最大不超过10英尺。通常甚至不到这个距离。它们一晚上可能会调查那个区域30次。它们不会只出去一次。
Well in a way what you're describing is almost the ideal animal to be caught.
从某种程度上说，你所描述的简直是理想的捕捉对象。
Exactly.
没错。
And so the problem for the mousetrap inventor is the world actually does not need a better mousetrap. The world will not beat its way to that person's door. Andy sells two mousetraps for $0.99 that do the job just great, 88% lethality. That is the reality of what a mousetrap inventor is competing with. Whereas the inventors almost never understand.
所以对于捕鼠器发明家来说，问题在于世界其实并不需要更好的捕鼠器。世界不会踏破那个人的门槛。安迪卖的捕鼠器0.99美元两个，效果非常好，致死率88%。这就是捕鼠器发明家所面对的现实。而发明家们几乎从不理解这一点。
Well they are always persistent, whether it's letters, or phone calls, or stopping here. They are passionate about their idea and are so disappointed when we turn them down.
嗯，他们总是很执着，无论是写信、打电话，还是亲自上门。他们对自己的想法充满热情，当我们拒绝他们时，他们感到非常失望。
Like they can't believe it.
就好像他们无法相信一样。
They can't believe it.
他们无法相信。
Because for them, there is the magic of the moment of invention, right? They actually came up with a new idea.
因为对他们来说，发明的那一刻是有魔力的，对吧？他们确实想出了一个新点子。
That's right.
没错。
And it turns out that's just not enough in this cold, cold world.
但事实证明，在这个冷酷无情的世界里，那还不够。
It's very hard. It's their baby. Again, they have nurtured this thing.
这很难。那是他们的心血结晶。再说一次，他们像养育孩子一样呵护着这个东西。
Well today on our program, we have four stories of inventions in a world that does not always need or want new ideas. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. We have four stories for you of ingenuity and heartbreak. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲四个关于发明的故事，在这个世界上，人们并不总是需要或想要新的想法。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们为你准备了四个关于独创性与心碎的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Mother of Invention. So we start with somebody inventing a new way to do something and in an area of life where you might not think there could be any new ways to do anything left. Karen Sosnoski tells the story. Her son Anton was born with Mosaic Down syndrome, which is this very rare form of Down Syndrome. Essentially some of his cells have the extra chromosome that causes Down Syndrome and the other cells don't. So as he grows, he could actually end up having all the health risks and challenges of Down Syndrome or very few of them. There's no way to know.
第一幕，发明之母。我们从一个发明某种新方法的人开始，这还是在生活中你可能认为不可能有任何新方法可言的领域。凯伦·索斯诺斯基讲述了这个故事。她的儿子安东出生时患有嵌合型唐氏综合征，这是一种非常罕见的唐氏综合征。本质上，他的一些细胞含有导致唐氏综合征的额外染色体，而另一些细胞则没有。因此，随着他的成长，他实际上可能最终会承担唐氏综合征的所有健康风险和挑战，也可能只会承担极少数。目前无法预知。
Some kids with MDS look totally normal but then have all kinds of learning disabilities. Others have all the physical features of a person with Down Syndrome but then have a high IQ. It's a diagnosis that's so vague it can drive a parent crazy. And Karen had no idea what the diagnosis would mean for her son's future. So she started doing some research. She found a Mosaic Down Syndrome website. And on that website, she started reading about a boy named Tim. A boy who, in a bunch of different ways, was not what she was expecting, and whose mom had invented a radical way of dealing with the diagnosis, something Karen had never heard of. Here she is.
一些患有MDS的孩子看起来完全正常，但却有各种学习障碍。另一些人则具有唐氏综合征患者的所有身体特征，但智商很高。这是一个如此模糊的诊断，以至于会让父母发疯。凯伦完全不知道这个诊断对她儿子的未来意味着什么。于是她开始做研究。她找到了一个嵌合型唐氏综合征网站。在那个网站上，她开始读到一个叫蒂姆的男孩的故事。这个男孩在很多方面都不是她所预期的那样，而且他的妈妈发明了一种处理这种诊断的激进方法，这是凯伦从未听说过的。下面请听她的讲述。
Tim was 13 when I first saw his picture on the internet. He had geeky, blunt-cut bangs and a wide, innocent smile. He had the same diagnosis as my son Anton, but he had the happy face of an ordinary boy. And when I looked at this photo, my heart raced with hope. Here was a kid I could imagine as my own. "A late bloomer," his mom wrote, but so what? He had hobbies and friends. He was a bookworm like I am.
我第一次在网上看到蒂姆的照片时，他13岁。他留着怪呆的平刘海，脸上带着灿烂天真的微笑。他和我的儿子安东有着同样的诊断结果，但他有着普通男孩那般快乐的面容。当我看着这张照片时，我的心因希望而狂跳。这正是我可以想象成为我儿子的那种孩子。“大器晚成”，他妈妈写道，但这又怎样呢？他有爱好，有朋友。他和我一样是个书虫。
To be honest, Tim's bio made me feel less guilty about Anton. Part of me blamed myself for what had happened. Everyone knew advanced maternal age was a major risk factor for having a baby with Down Syndrome. And here I'd waited until 40 to have him. But maybe if I played my cards absolutely right from here on in, he could still turn out just fine.
老实说，蒂姆的经历让我对安东感到少了一些内疚。我内心的一部分责怪自己造成了这一切。每个人都知道高龄产妇生下唐氏综合征婴儿是一个主要的风险因素。而我等到40岁才生他。但也许如果我从现在起把每一步都走好，他仍然可以成长得很好。
Tim's mother, Kristy, was like a role model for me. She founded an international support group for parents of kids with Mosaic Down Syndrome. She wanted us to be sure the world gave them a fair shake, and I like this. But to make this happen for her own son, she did something I could never have imagined, something that shocks people every time I tell them. For years, she kept her son's diagnosis a secret. She didn't tell his teachers. She didn't tell her neighbors. And most incredibly, for the first 14 years of his life, she didn't tell Tim.
蒂姆的母亲克里斯蒂就像我的榜样。她为嵌合型唐氏综合征儿童的父母创立了一个国际支持小组。她想确保世界能公平地对待他们，我喜欢这一点。但为了给自己的儿子实现这一点，她做了一件我无法想象的事情，一件我每次告诉别人都会让他们感到震惊的事情。多年来，她一直隐瞒儿子的诊断结果。她没有告诉他的老师。她没有告诉邻居。而最令人难以置信的是，在她儿子生命的前14年里，她甚至没有告诉蒂姆。
I first heard Kristy talk about her secret at a conference. Then, a couple months ago, I left my one year old son Anton for the first time and travelled down to Texas to find out more from Kristy and Tim. How had Tim turned out so well? How much of it was because she had kept his diagnosis a secret? She told me she didn't start off planning to deceive anyone. When Tim started kindergarten, Kristy did what most parents do. She didn't keep his disability a secret. She explained to the teachers that he had Mosaic Down Syndrome. She asked the teachers to treat him like any other kid, and she crossed her fingers. But it didn't work out as she had planned. This is Kristy.
我第一次听克里斯蒂谈论她的秘密是在一个会议上。几个月前，我第一次离开我一岁的儿子安东，前往德克萨斯州，想从克里斯蒂和蒂姆那里了解更多。蒂姆是怎么变得这么优秀的？这在多大程度上是因为她隐瞒了他的诊断结果？她告诉我，她一开始并没有打算欺骗任何人。蒂姆上幼儿园时，克里斯蒂做了大多数父母会做的事。她没有隐瞒他的残疾。她向老师解释他患有嵌合型唐氏综合征。她请求老师像对待普通孩子一样对待他，然后祈祷一切顺利。但事情并没有像她计划的那样发展。这就是克里斯蒂。
I know one time I went in there to visit the classroom, and all the little children are sitting up in their nice little story time circle. And he's lying in the middle of the carpet, rolling around and lying around. And I asked the teacher, why is he laying when everyone else is sitting down? And she said, well he likes to do that. And we just want to make him happy. And so it was because he had Mosaic Down Syndrome. And so I knew then, maybe it's not a good idea for everybody to know because they are going to make excuses for him. And I wanted him more than anything to just be as normal as normal is, to have the same opportunities that everyone else had. So the next year when school began, I didn't tell his teacher.
记得有一次我去教室探望，所有的孩子们都坐在漂亮的讲故事圆圈里。而他却躺在地毯中间，滚来滚去。我问老师，为什么别人都在坐着时他却躺着？她说，哦，他喜欢那样。我们只是想让他高兴。所以这就是因为他患有嵌合型唐氏综合征。所以我那时就明白，也许让所有人都知道并不是个好主意，因为他们会为他找借口。我最希望的就是他能像正常人一样正常，拥有和其他人一样的机会。所以第二年学校开始时，我没有告诉他的老师。
And then we thought, if he knows that he has Mosaic Down Syndrome, he's going to use that for a crutch, big time. So we decided, we're just not going to tell him until he gets a little bit older.
后来我们想，如果他知道自己患有嵌合型唐氏综合征，他会非常严重地把它当作借口。所以我们决定，在他长大一点之前，我们就不告诉他了。
Which could get kind of complicated. She had to talk behind Tim's back and over his head. She had to tell family members never to mention Tim's condition in front of him.
这可能会变得很复杂。她必须在蒂姆背后议论，并背着他说话。她不得不告诉家庭成员永远不要在他面前提起蒂姆的情况。
And it's OK if you people know it, but I don't want him to know it. I turned into a tricky person.
你们知道没关系，但我不想让他知道。我变成了一个诡计多端的人。
Were there times when you were tempted to tell him?
有没有什么时候你很想告诉他？
One time stands out really, really deeply in my mind. He was around 10 years old, and he had a little treehouse. And all the kids would come over to be in his treehouse with him. And this one little boy in our neighborhood had Down Syndrome. And I looked outside. All the kids are playing. And Tim pushed this little boy down. And I was like, "No, you don't push him down. That's not nice." And I made him come inside and I said, "Why did you push this little boy down?" And he goes, "I don't like him. He looks different." That crushed me. That crushed me. And I said, "Well, why don't you like him? Just because he looks different? Everybody looks different." And he said, "No, he talks funny. I don't like him." And I wanted so much at that point to say don't you know that you have the same chromosomes as him?
有一件事在我脑海中印象非常非常深刻。他当时大约10岁，有一个小树屋。所有的孩子都会过来和他一起在树屋里玩。我们社区里有个小男孩患有唐氏综合征。我向外看去。所有的孩子都在玩。蒂姆把那个小男孩推倒了。我当时说：“不，你不可以推他。那是不礼貌的。”我让他进屋，问他：“你为什么要推那个小男孩？”他说：“我不喜欢他。他看起来不一样。”那让我心碎。那让我心碎。我说：“嗯，你为什么不喜欢他？就因为他看起来不一样？每个人看起来都不一样。”他说：“不，他说话怪怪的。我不喜欢他。”那时我多么想说，难道你不知道你和他拥有同样的染色体吗？
When I was a lot younger I used to think that because I was different I thought maybe I was from another world, that I was an alien or something.
我小的时候常想，因为我与众不同，我觉得自己可能来自另一个世界，是个外星人什么的。
This is Tim. He's almost 20 now but he doesn't look much older than his picture at 13. It's not super obvious that he has a medical condition, but if you're at all tuned into Down Syndrome, you can probably guess. His eyes have those extra folds, and he talks in a slow careful way like he's having to work to shape his words.
这就是蒂姆。他现在快20岁了，但看起来并不比他13岁时的照片老多少。虽然他患有某种医疗状况并不是特别明显，但如果你稍微了解唐氏综合征，你可能就能猜出来。他的眼睛有那种多余的褶皱，他说话的方式缓慢而谨慎，好像他必须努力组织自己的词汇一样。
Academically though, Tim blows any stereotypes about Down Syndrome out of the water. His IQ is 110, higher than the national average. He got A's and B's with no special help at a mainstream school. But by junior high, Tim was starting to have a hard time fitting in with other kids. He would do weird things like burp or rock on his heels in class. He'd say inappropriate things, like the time he got so excited about a slasher movie that he confused himself with the main character. "I started shooting people," he told the kids at his lunch table. As you can imagine, he didn't make a lot of friends this way.
不过在学业上，蒂姆打破了关于唐氏综合征的所有刻板印象。他的智商是110，高于全国平均水平。他在主流学校没有得到任何特殊帮助的情况下就拿到了A和B。但到了初中，蒂姆开始难以融入其他孩子。他会做一些奇怪的事情，比如在课堂上打嗝或用脚后跟摇晃。他会说一些不恰当的话，比如有一次他因为一部恐怖电影而太兴奋，竟然把自己和主角混为一谈。“我开始射杀人了，”他告诉午餐桌上的孩子们。你可以想象，他这样并没能交到多少朋友。
All I knew is that I was different because people were bothering me all the time.
我只知道我与众不同，因为人们一直在我身上找茬。
Can you give an example?
你能举个例子吗？
Insults, being picked on, teased, hazing-- if you know what that is.
侮辱、被针对、嘲弄、恶作剧——如果你知道那是什么的话。
Tim started realizing that there was something different about him. And when Tim was around 12 years old, we were on our way to the grocery store. And I was driving and Tim was sitting in the front seat next to me. And we hadn't been talking at all. I mean the radio is going. We're not listening to-- talking to each other. And all of a sudden--
蒂姆开始意识到自己有些不同。当蒂姆大约12岁时，我们在去杂货店的路上。我在开车，蒂姆坐在我旁边的副驾驶座上。我们一直没说话。收音机开着。我们没有听——没在交谈。突然——
I asked my mom, "Do I have a medical problem that you don't want to tell me about because you think I'm not mature enough to handle it?"
我问妈妈：“我有什么你不想告诉我的医疗问题吗？因为你觉得我不够成熟，处理不了？”
We pulled over at the park. And I stopped the car. And I looked at him and I said, "Why do you want to know this?" And he said, "You know, I just know that I'm different."
我们把车停在公园里。我停下车。我看着他说：“你为什么想知道这个？”他说：“你知道，我只是感觉到我与众不同。”
But she couldn't bring herself to tell him the truth. She didn't know if Tim was ready, and she didn't feel ready. She said nothing.
但她无法让自己告诉他真相。她不知道蒂姆是否准备好了，她自己也没有准备好。她什么也没说。
I was really-- probably lost sleep over it because I kept going back and forth with, have I done the right thing keeping this from him? But at that time I wasn't sure. No matter how hard I tried to make his world so great, still kids picked on him. And so as years progressed, one day he came home and he was about 14. And he came home and he said, "Mom, I feel like I'm the only person in the whole world who has the same problems as me." And it just broke my heart.
我真的——大概为此彻夜难眠，因为我一直在纠结，隐瞒他是不是做对了？但那时我不确定。无论我多么努力地让他的世界变得美好，孩子们依然会针对他。随着岁月流逝，有一天他大约14岁时回到家。他回家说：“妈妈，我觉得我是世界上唯一一个有我这种问题的人。”那真是让我心碎。
My husband came home from work that night. And I said, "We're going to have to probably pretty soon tell him."
那天晚上我丈夫下班回家。我说：“我们可能很快就得告诉他了。”
But they didn't. For another six whole months. It seemed so difficult. Here Kristy had to tell Tim that she had kept the fundamental truth about his identity from him for most of his life. What's more, it seemed that her efforts to protect him might have actually made things worse.
但他们没说。又过了整整六个月。这看起来太难了。在这里，克里斯蒂不得不告诉蒂姆，她在大多数时间里一直对他隐瞒了他身份的根本真相。更重要的是，她保护他的努力似乎反而让事情变得更糟了。
I think that we just worried how he was going to react. We didn't know how he was going to. We didn't know what to expect at all whatsoever. We didn't know if he would be happy or mad or sad or what. We just didn't know what to expect at all. And so I think that was our main worry. So we sat down on the couch. My husband tried to leave. And so Tim comes in from his bedroom and sits down. And I said, "We've got something to tell you." And he said, "What?" I said, "Remember how a while back you asked me if you had a medical problem that I didn't want you to know about?" And he said yes. And I said, "Do you remember when you said you felt like you're the only person in the whole world who had the problems that you had?" And he said yes.
我想我们只是担心他的反应。我们不知道他会怎么样。我们完全不知道会发生什么。我们不知道他是会高兴、愤怒还是悲伤，或者是什么。我们根本不知道该期待什么。所以我认为这是我们主要的担忧。于是我们坐在沙发上。我丈夫想离开。然后蒂姆从卧室出来坐下。我说：“我们有话要告诉你。”他说：“什么？”我说：“记得前一阵子你问我，你是不是有什么医疗问题，而我不想让你知道吗？”他说记得。我说：“你还记得你说你觉得你是世界上唯一一个有你那种问题的人吗？”他说记得。
She told me I had Mosaic Down Syndrome. I don't know her exact words, but that's what she said.
她告诉我我患有嵌合型唐氏综合征。我不记得她确切的话了，但她就是那么说的。
What came into your mind when she told you that?
当你得知这个消息时，你脑子里想到了什么？
Storm, Cyclops, Rogue, X-Men.
暴风女、独眼龙、罗刹女、X战警。
Why did X-Men come into your mind?
为什么你会想到X战警？
Because the X-Men are mutants, genetic. They gain those genetic problems. And that's what I felt like. I felt like an X-Men. I thought that was kind of cool.
因为X战警是变种人，基因突变。他们获得了那些基因问题。那就是我的感觉。我觉得自己是个X战警。我觉得那挺酷的。
And just like that, the truth was out. Ironically, what happened next was exactly the opposite of what Kristy had feared. Tim didn't seem angry. He didn't stop trying in school. The diagnosis actually made him more conscious of his strange behaviors, like the rocking on his heels, so he could work harder at controlling them. Mostly he was relieved. He had spent so many years feeling like there was something wrong with him that finding out there was wasn't so bad.
就这样，真相大白了。讽刺的是，接下来的情况与克里斯蒂所担心的完全相反。蒂姆似乎并没有生气。他并没有放弃学习。诊断结果反而让他更意识到自己的怪异行为，比如用脚后跟摇晃，所以他可以更努力地去控制它们。最重要的是他感到释然。他花了这么多年觉得自己在某些方面不对劲，结果发现情况并没有那么糟糕。
In his junior year, Tim came out to his classmates during a presentation on genetics. After that, the kids started cutting him some slack. He wasn't the weird kid anymore. He was a kid with that Mosaic Down thing. And you couldn't blame him for that.
在高二那年，蒂姆在一次遗传学展示中向同学们公开了自己的情况。在那之后，孩子们开始对他宽容了一些。他不再是那个怪胎了。他是那个患有“嵌合型唐氏综合征”的孩子。而你不能因此而责怪他。
So that was a real big turning point. He got a bunch of friends, real friends. And it was our first time to have real friends. And then all these three big teenage boys came back to our house to spend the night. Never had such a thing, I mean never. And so they're going to spend the night. And so we've got all these boys and I'm going, we have to make popcorn. We have to watch movies. And after I got them settled, I came in the bedroom and I bawled my head off because it was just so wonderful. In fact it was 10:30 at night and I'm calling my mother, "I have teenage boys in the house."
所以那真是一个巨大的转折点。他交了一群朋友，真正的朋友。这是我们第一次拥有真正的朋友。然后这三个大男孩回到我家过夜。从未有过这样的事，我的意思是从来没有。所以他们要过夜。我们有这么多男孩，我心想，我们得做爆米花。我们得看电影。把他们安顿好之后，我回到卧室，哭得稀里哗啦，因为这实在太美好了。事实上当时是晚上10点半，我还在给妈妈打电话：“我家里有高中男生。”
You would think, given how things turned out, Kristy might have had some regrets about waiting so long to tell Tim the truth. I kept waiting for her to crack or something during our interview, to admit she had made a mistake. But she didn't. And frankly, I was relieved. I don't want to cast judgment on Kristy. Tim's a great kid. Whether that's because of what Kristy did or in spite of it, I don't think anyone can say. And anyway, Kristy and Tim have moved on to other issues like teaching Tim how to balance a checkbook, how to drive, how to get ready to live on his own. And from Tim's point of view, Kristy has her own learning to do.
考虑到事情的结果，你可能会认为克里斯蒂会对自己等了这么久才告诉蒂姆真相感到有些后悔。我在采访中一直等着她崩溃或者什么，承认她犯了一个错误。但她没有。坦率地说，我感到很欣慰。我不想对克里斯蒂评头论足。蒂姆是个好孩子。无论这是因为克里斯蒂所做的，还是尽管如此才变成这样，我想没人能说得清。无论如何，克里斯蒂和蒂姆已经转而处理其他问题，比如教蒂姆如何平衡支票簿，如何开车，如何准备独立生活。而从蒂姆的角度来看，克里斯蒂自己也有要学习的地方。
My mom is being a control freak right now. I'm going to be 20 this May. It's time I started to be a bit more independent.
我妈现在是个控制狂。我今年5月就20岁了。我该变得更独立了。
How will you have to change to be more independent?
为了变得更独立，你需要做出什么改变？
When I leave this house, I plan to never wash the dishes again.
等我搬出这个家，我打算再也不洗碗了。
Who's going to wash them?
谁来洗呢？
My wife. I'm kidding. I'll have the kids do it.
我老婆。开玩笑的。我会让孩子们洗。
It's funny, or maybe just typical. Tim's critical of his mom, but when I ask him how he thinks I should raise Anton, his advice to me is to do just what she did. "Let people get to know Anton first before you tell them anything," Tim says to me. "Tell Anton when he's a teenager, when he's old enough to handle it." I know I probably won't do this. After all, Kristy's secrecy didn't protect Tim from pain, which is what I want for my son. So I'm back to square one with no trick to give Anton the perfect future, any more than I could give him those perfect chromosomes. I'm like any other parent, waiting to see who my son becomes.
这很有趣，或者也许很典型。蒂姆对妈妈很挑剔，但当我问他认为我该如何养育安东时，他给我的建议是做她做过的事。“让人们先了解安东，然后再告诉他们任何事，”蒂姆对我说。“等安东十几岁，足够成熟能处理这些事时再告诉他。”我知道我可能不会这样做。毕竟，克里斯蒂的隐瞒并没有保护蒂姆免受伤害，而这正是我想要的。所以，我回到了原点，没有给安东完美未来的秘诀，正如我也无法给他那些完美的染色体一样。我和其他父母一样，等待着看我的儿子会成为什么样的人。
Karen Sosnoski in Alexandria, Virginia.
凯伦·索斯诺斯基，弗吉尼亚州亚历山大市。
[MUSIC  - "I KNOW WHO I AM" BY BUNNY RUGGS]
[音乐 - 邦尼·拉格斯的《我知道我是谁》]
Act Two, Everything Must Go. In the early 1990's, Sudhir Alladi Venkatesh was researching the underground economies in the city of Chicago. He was a grad student back then. He wanted to know how people made money off the books, and he spent a lot of time in the poorer areas of the city where people had to invent ways to make their own livings. He hung out with women selling food from their homes, car mechanics who ran their business from an alleyway, store owners who hosted late night gambling and dice games. None of them was reporting their income to the government. Then there was Nellie, who had a problem that not many people faced. Here's Sudhir.
第二幕，一切都要清空。20世纪90年代初，苏迪尔·阿拉迪·文卡泰什正在研究芝加哥市的地下经济。那时他还是个研究生。他想知道人们如何在账外赚钱，并在城市里较贫困的地区花了很多时间，那里的人们必须创造各种方法来谋生。他经常和在家售卖食物的妇女、在小巷里经营修车生意的技工、经营深夜赌博和掷骰子游戏的店主混在一起。他们中没有人向政府申报收入。还有内莉，他面临着一个没多少人会遇到的问题。下面请听苏迪尔的讲述。
Nellie Thomas was a hustler who worked in and around his South Side neighborhood. And over the course of his life, he was a pimp, drug dealer, car thief, extorter, jack roller, prostitute and burglar. I met Nellie because I wanted to know how people bought guns in Chicago. By the time I met him, Nellie had made a name for himself, not because he sold guns but because he sold ammunition.
内莉·托马斯是个混迹于南区社区内外的江湖混混。他的一生中，做过皮条客、毒贩、偷车贼、敲诈者、强盗、妓女和盗贼。我认识内莉是因为我想知道人们如何在芝加哥买枪。我认识他的时候，内莉已经小有名气，不是因为他卖枪，而是因为他卖弹药。
It's illegal to buy handguns in the city of Chicago. For guns and ammo, people usually have to trek out to the suburbs, which isn't so easy. Most gun stores are in white suburbs, and the black people in Nellie's community don't like to go there. So they buy guns in their own neighborhood for the most part. Now, in the South Side where Nellie lived, if you have money and a little patience, you can probably find a gun within a few days. But it's a lot harder to find ammo.
在芝加哥市购买手枪是非法的。对于枪支和弹药，人们通常不得不跋涉到郊区，这并不容易。大多数枪店都在白人聚居的郊区，而内莉社区里的黑人不喜欢去那里。所以他们大部分时间是在自己的社区里买枪。现在，在内莉居住的南区，如果你有钱且有一点耐心，你可能在几天内就能找到一把枪。但要找到弹药要困难得多。
Nellie understood this, and he capitalized on the demand by becoming an ammunitions trader. Nellie would drive to the suburbs or he would hire people to go there and buy boxes of ammo for a few dollars each. Back in his own neighborhood, it might cost you a $100 for a box. He sold bullets to gang members, robbers, drug dealers, prostitutes and just regular people who liked to have a weapon around. And when the gang wars heated up in the mid to late 90's, people bought several boxes at a time and Nellie was flush with cash. "Good money, no hassle," he liked to say. "Cops don't care much about me."
内莉明白这一点，他通过成为一名弹药交易商利用了这种需求。内莉会开车去郊区，或者雇用别人去那里买几盒几块钱的弹药。回到他自己的社区，一盒弹药可能要花你100美元。他把子弹卖给帮派成员、强盗、毒贩、妓女以及仅仅喜欢随身带把枪的普通人。当90年代中期帮派战争升温时，人们一次买好几盒，内莉口袋里装满了现金。“好赚，没麻烦，”他喜欢这么说。“警察不太关心我。”
When I started hanging out with Nellie, he was becoming bothered by his success. He was making so much money that he didn't know what to do with it. His needs were pretty minimal. He had a beat-up old truck that he fixed himself, and his parents had long ago paid off the mortgage on the bungalow where he was born and where he still lived. The house was a modest, two-story and basement and backyard design that you could see all over Chicago. Nellie was hardly a big consumer. He liked to listen to a pocket-size radio, and although he had a fancy TV, he usually watched a little black and white in his bedroom. And he never traveled.
我刚开始和内莉混在一起时，他的成功让他感到困扰。他赚了太多的钱，以至于不知道该怎么处理。他的需求非常少。他有一辆破旧的卡车，自己修理，他的父母很久以前就付清了他出生并一直居住的那栋平房的抵押贷款。房子是一种在芝加哥随处可见的朴实的两层带地下室和后院的设计。内莉几乎不是什么大消费者。他喜欢听袖珍收音机，尽管有一台高级电视，但他通常只在卧室里看那台黑白小电视。他从不出远门。
For 20 years, he'd been eating at the same soul food restaurant every day. He wore the same three or four pairs of clothes. And almost every day you could see him walking or playing golf-- very badly he said-- in the park next to his house. Nellie also lived in a world of cash. Like most underground traders, he couldn't take large sums of money to the bank. And for small sums, he simply didn't trust banks. So he put his cash in mattresses and in large, black trash bags that he hid inside his house or that he buried outside in the backyard.
20年来，他每天都在同一家灵魂乐餐厅吃饭。他穿的那三四套衣服也一直没变过。几乎每天你都能看到他在房子旁边的公园里走路或打高尔夫球——他说他打得很烂。内莉也生活在一个现金世界里。像大多数地下交易商一样，他不能把大笔钱存进银行。而对于小额款项，他就是不信任银行。所以他把现金放在床垫里，或者装在大的黑色垃圾袋里，藏在家里，或者埋在后院外面。
But Nellie was losing sleep because he was running out of places to keep his cash. He worried because there were other people living in his home, a girlfriend and her two children, a niece, his grandmother, an aunt and a brother with his girlfriend and two kids. Nellie was scared he'd be robbed. And so he began staying up all night with a big shotgun next to his window. His anxiety grew so bad that he started taking medication and drinking more. He was restless and fidgety, and he said he was yelling at his family for no good reason.
但内莉失眠了，因为他快没地方藏现金了。他很担心，因为家里还住着其他人，一个女朋友和她的两个孩子，一个侄女，他的祖母，一个姑妈，还有他弟弟和他女朋友及两个孩子。内莉害怕被抢劫。于是他开始整夜坐在窗边，手里握着一把大散弹枪。他的焦虑变得非常严重，以至于他开始服用药物并喝更多的酒。他坐立不安，烦躁易怒，他说他总是无缘无故地对家人大吼大叫。
Sometimes he would call me early in the morning. We both knew many of the local gang leaders, and he wanted me to tell him whether they were planning to raid his house. He also asked me strange questions, like whether squirrels could smell paper money and whether they would dig in his backyard and eat his holdings. He admitted he was going to the hospital nearly every two weeks due to panic attacks.
有时他会在清晨给我打电话。我们都知道许多当地的帮派头目，他想让我告诉他他们是否计划洗劫他的房子。他还问我一些奇怪的问题，比如松鼠是否能闻出纸币的味道，它们是否会在他的后院挖洞吃掉他的积蓄。他承认他几乎每两周就会因惊恐发作而去医院。
At first I wondered why Nellie didn't just give his money away to his family or to a charity. But it wasn't so simple for him. He said he was ashamed of how he had earned it. He didn't want to tell people that he sold ammo to gang members for a living. I suppose Nellie could have bought some property or found a way to launder his money, but that really wasn't in his character. Nellie didn't think in terms of the future, at least not in that way. And because he was very depressed and his job was so dangerous, Nellie didn't think he'd live long enough to spend his money on anything worthwhile.
起初我纳闷，内莉为什么不把钱给家人或捐给慈善机构。但这对他来说没那么简单。他说他对赚钱的方式感到羞耻。他不想告诉别人他是靠卖弹药给帮派成员谋生的。我想内莉本可以买些房产或者找个洗钱的方法，但这真的不是他的性格。内莉不从未来角度思考问题，至少不会那样想。而且因为他非常沮丧，他的工作又非常危险，内莉认为他活不到把这些钱花在有意义的事情上的那一天。
One morning I went to Nellie's house and found him in tears. No one was home, and he was lying on his bed with his money all over the room. He kept saying he couldn't take it anymore and he wanted a way out. I noticed a few large bills, but there were mostly piles and piles of $1 and $5 bills crumpled up like waste paper. He was pleading with me to help him to do something with all of his money, which he estimated was about $15,000 or $20,000. He asked me, "What do your people do when they have all this stuff that they can't use?" I'm Indian, but I assumed he meant middle class folks. "Well," I said, "when my family has a lot of stuff, we give it away or we have a garage sale." His eyes lit up. "That's it. I'm going to have a garage sale."
一天早上我去内莉家，发现他正在哭泣。家里没人，他躺在床上，满屋子都是钱。他一直说他受不了了，想找个出路。我注意到有几张大面额钞票，但大部分都是堆积如山的1美元和5美元纸币，像废纸一样皱成一团。他恳求我帮他处理这些钱，他估计大约有1.5万到2万美元。他问我：“你们那种人有这么多用不掉的东西时会怎么办？”我是印度人，但我猜他指的是中产阶级。“嗯，”我说，“我们家有很多东西时，我们会把它们送人，或者举行庭院义卖。”他的眼睛亮了。“就是这个。我要举行庭院义卖。”
I wasn't sure I understood what he meant. "Let me get this straight. You're going to sell your money?" He grinned, stood up, hugged me and said, "Thank you, thank you, thank you for getting me out of this mess."
我不确定我是否理解他的意思。“等一下，我没听错吧。你要卖钱？”他咧嘴一笑，站起身来拥抱我，说：“谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你帮我摆脱了这个烂摊子。”
So I made myself a cup of coffee, sat on the couch and watched as Nellie put some of the money inside a television. Then he dumped a handful of bills inside a vacuum cleaner. Then he shoved bags full of cash inside his couch cushions and in a mattress. He picked up a basketball, examined it, looked over to me and agreed when I shook my head no.
于是我给自己倒了杯咖啡，坐在沙发上看着内莉把一些钱塞进电视机里。然后他把一把钞票倒进了吸尘器里。接着他又把装满现金的袋子塞进沙发垫里和床垫里。他拿起一个篮球，端详了一下，看向我，在我摇头表示不行时，他也表示赞同。
And then with my help he dragged everything out to the front lawn. He ran into the garage and came back with a hammer, nails and cardboard. He made several For Sale signs and tacked them onto the trees and on the windshield of his car. He was so happy. He was running around like a child building a treehouse. For his final gesture, Nellie ran back inside the house, grabbed two chairs and a six-pack of beer and brought them outside. He told me that I couldn't tell anyone what he just did.
然后在我帮助下，他把所有东西都拖到了前草坪上。他跑进车库，拿着锤子、钉子和纸板出来。他做了几个“出售”的牌子，钉在树上和汽车挡风玻璃上。他非常高兴。他像个在盖树屋的孩子一样跑来跑去。最后，内莉跑回屋里，拿了两把椅子和一打啤酒出来。他告诉我，不准把刚才发生的事告诉任何人。
I exchanged my coffee for a beer and sat on Nellie's well  manicured front lawn, unsure of exactly what was supposed to transpire. We sat on the lawn for about 10 minutes. I was getting a little agitated. My cell phone rang. Nellie looked at me and said, "Remember, you can't say what's in them things. You can't mention the money."
我放下咖啡换成啤酒，坐在内莉修剪整齐的前草坪上，不确定到底会发生什么。我们在草坪上坐了大约10分钟。我开始有点不安。手机响了。内莉看着我说：“记住，不能说那些东西里有什么。不能提钱的事。”
It was a friend of mine, Autry. He had three children, and he had been looking for a job for about a year. And now he was living off food stamps and was about three months late on his car and rent payments. Autry could definitely have used the money, not to mention the nice TV set sitting in front of my feet. "I'm at a garage sale," I told Autry, checking with Nellie to see if that was OK. Nellie nodded approval. "You should come over," I said, checking with Nellie again, who didn't nod. "Autry, listen, you should really come over and see if anything interests you."
是我朋友奥特里的电话。他有三个孩子，已经找了一年工作了。现在他靠救济券过活，房租和车贷已经欠了三个月了。奥特里绝对用得上这些钱，更别说我脚边那台漂亮的电视机了。“我在举行庭院义卖，”我告诉奥特里，确认一下内莉是否同意。内莉点了点头表示赞同。“你应该过来，”我说，再次看了看内莉，他没点头。“奥特里，听着，你真应该过来看看有什么感兴趣的东西。”
Autry asked me why the hell would I want him to come to a garage sale when I knew he didn't have any money. I kept telling him to come anyway. Nellie began shaking his head. I sank in my chair, lowered my voice and told Autry to call me if he found some cash and wanted to buy some appliances. And then I hung up.
奥特里问我，明知道他没钱，为什么还要让他来参加什么义卖。我一直让他过来。内莉开始摇头。我缩进椅子里，压低声音告诉奥特里，如果他凑到钱想买些电器就打电话给我。然后我挂了电话。
Nellie and I waited for what seemed like hours, though my watch said only 20 minutes had passed. Every so often I asked him again whether he really wanted to do this. He would just stare out and tell me that he'd never been more sure about anything in his life. "I feel like the Lord gave me a sign," he said.
内莉和我等了似乎有几个小时，尽管我的表显示才过了20分钟。我每隔一会儿就会问他是否真的想这么做。他只是盯着前方，告诉我他这辈子从来没这么确定过一件事。“我觉得上帝给了我一个启示，”他说。
Just then a woman came by and looked at the couch. I leaned forward as if to pounce out of my chair. And I could see that Nellie was doing the same. "Nice couch," she said. "Yes," said Nellie, "you ain't never gonna find another one like it." "That's right ma'am," I chimed in. "This is certainly a one of a kind couch. You can take my word for it." "$20," she said. "For a couch?" said Nellie. "Ma'am, I need to make a little more than that." "But sir," she said, trying to be polite, "it ain't worth more than that." "Ma'am," I said, "I think on that count you are mistaken. It is certainly worth more." "Hey, shut up," Nellie yelled at me. The woman watched as Nellie and I began bickering. "You two need help," she said and walked away.
就在这时，一个女人走过来看着沙发。我向前倾，仿佛要从椅子上扑出去。我可以看到内莉也一样。“漂亮的沙发，”她说。“是的，”内莉说，“你绝对找不到另一台这样的了。”“没错女士，”我附和道。“这绝对是独一无二的沙发。你可以相信我。”“20美元，”她说。“买沙发？”内莉说。“女士，我得再多卖点。”“但是先生，”她说，礼貌地试着说，“它不值那么多钱。”“女士，”我说，“我认为这一点你错了。它绝对不止这个价。”“嘿，闭嘴，”内莉对我吼道。那个女人看着我和内莉开始争吵。“你们俩需要找人帮忙，”她说，转身走了。
As the morning turned to afternoon, more people came. The first successful sale was to a man pushing a shopping cart. He eyed the vacuum cleaner. "What do you want for it?" he asked. "Give me 15," said Nellie. "15, are you nuts?" I said. I couldn't believe Nellie would charge so little. Nellie shot me a glance and I put my head in my hands. "15 my man and it's all yours," Nellie said calmly. "All right, that'll work," the mad said. He paid Nellie with some bills and a lot of loose change. The he grinned and said within an hour he could sell the vacuum cleaner down at the thrift store for $30, double his take just like that.
随着上午变成下午，人多了起来。第一笔成功的交易是一个推着购物车的男人。他看中了吸尘器。“这玩意儿你要多少钱？”他问。“给我15，”内莉说。“15，你疯了吗？”我说。我不敢相信内莉开价这么低。内莉给了我一个眼色，我双手抱头。 “15块，伙计，归你了，”内莉冷静地说。“好，行，”那人说。他付给内莉一些钞票和一大堆零钱。然后他咧嘴一笑说，他可以在一小时内把吸尘器卖给旧货店，能卖30美元，直接翻倍。
"You might want to take it home first," I told the man as he started walking away. Just clean it out. Put a fresh bag in. Try it out. Take it apart maybe." "Home," the man said looking at me. "Boy, are you blind or something? I live out of this cart. I live under the L tracks. Home? [BLEEP] I ain't got no home. What the [BLEEP] am I going to do with a vacuum cleaner?"
“你可能想先把它带回家，”我告诉那个男人，当他开始走远时，“彻底清理一下。装个新的袋子。试用一下。也许把它拆开看看。”“家，”那个人看着我说，“孩子，你是瞎了吗？我就住在推车里。我住在L型轨道下面。家？见鬼，我根本没家。我拿个吸尘器能干什么？”
A Saturday morning church service must have ended because a line of black women wearing beautiful dresses and hats was coming our way. They looked at the items on the lawn and liked what they saw. One played with the television set, hitting it every so often while a few other sat on the couch. "A little soft, and well, not so even," one said to me and Nellie. "These cushions are a little old, aren't they? How old are they?" "Oh, they're fairly new," I said. "Made fresh this morning actually." "Boy," Nellie yelled at me. This time he threw some beer on me. "Don't mind him, ma'am. He's not the God fearing sort. You understand." The woman cast a disparaging look my way and said, "Mm-hmm. I understand. And Jesus do too. OK, I'll take this couch. Probably throw these cushions away. The other parts are fine, but I can't have people sitting on these raggedy things all day."
星期六早上的礼拜一定是结束了，一排穿着漂亮裙子和戴着帽子的黑人妇女正朝我们走来。她们看了看草坪上的物品，看起来很喜欢。一个人摆弄着电视机，不时拍打它，而另外几个坐在沙发上。“有点软，而且不太平整，”其中一个对我和内莉说。“这些垫子有点老了，不是吗？用了多久了？”“哦，它们相当新，”我说，“其实是今天早上刚做好的。”“孩子，”内莉对我大喊。这次他把啤酒泼在我身上。“别介意他，女士。他不是那种敬畏上帝的人。你明白的。”那个女人轻蔑地看了我一眼说：“嗯，我明白。上帝也明白。好的，我要这台沙发。我可能会把这些垫子扔了。其他部分都挺好，但我不能让人整天坐在这些破烂玩意儿上。”
"I would rethink that strategy," I shouted. My voice crackled and beer spilled down my shirt. "I would probably not throw them away just yet." "What he means to say," Nellie interrupted, "is that you may want to take it home first. Don't do anything so quick. You know, take your time." "Not sure there's really anything to think about," a second woman said, feeling the cushions stuffed with America's legal tender. "Eunella, you could replace these for $5. Ain't no need wasting your time with these cushions. Smell like cat piss anyway. Just throw them out."
“我劝你三思而后行，”我喊道。我的声音沙哑，啤酒顺着衬衫流下来。“我可能不会现在就扔掉它们。”“他的意思是，”内莉插话道，“你可能想先把它带回家。别做那么快。你知道，慢慢来。”“不确定有什么可考虑的，”第二个女人说，摸着塞满了美国法定货币的垫子，“尤内拉，你可以花5美元换这些垫子。没必要浪费时间在这些垫子上。反正闻起来像猫尿。直接扔了吧。”
"Oh Lord, I would really think twice about that," I said bending over in frustration. I was starting to feel delirious. "Why don't you go inside for a while?" Nellie said, pushing me over and making me fall on the ground. I got up and walked toward the house. "What is wrong with that young man?" I could hear the woman ask Nellie. "Oh, nothing that a little religion couldn't fix," Nellie said. Then he told them, "Listen, the truth is ma'am that I'm trying to buy my family all new furniture before they get home. And I really need to sell this stuff and get rid of it so that I can surprise my wife."
“哦上帝，我真的会三思，”我说，颓然弯下腰。我开始感到神志不清。“你为什么不进去待一会儿？”内莉说，把我推倒在地。我爬起来，朝房子走去。“那个年轻人怎么了？”我能听到那个女人问内莉。“哦，没什么一点宗教信仰解决不了的，”内莉说。然后他告诉她们，“听着，女士，真相是我正想在家人回家前给他们买套全新的家具。我真的需要把这些旧的卖掉，腾出地方，好给我妻子一个惊喜。”
"Oh, isn't that sweet?" one of the women said. "Well, I'll take the television." "Yes," another one chimed in. "And I could use an extra bed." "I would keep that mattress," I shouted from inside the house. "Don't throw away the mattress, please." "That is the strangest young man I have ever seen," one of the women said. "Yes, said Nellie. He twirled his finger in little circles next to his head. "He has a little bit of trouble, you know."
“哦，这不是很贴心吗？”其中一个女人说。“好吧，我要这台电视。”“是的，”另一个人附和道。“我也正需要一张多余的床。”“请留下那个床垫，”我在屋内大喊，“请别扔掉那个床垫。”“那是我见过最奇怪的年轻人，”其中一个女人说。“是的，”内莉说，他在自己头边比划着画圈，“他脑子有点问题，你知道的。”
The woman then turned to me and spoke very slowly. "You be careful now young man. And beer probably isn't very good for your health." "Neither is throwing away that mattress ma'am."
那个女人然后转向我，非常缓慢地说话。“年轻人，你小心点。啤酒对你的健康可能不太好。”“扔掉那个床垫对你的健康也不太好，女士。”
Nellie asked the women for their address and he loaded the bed into the truck and drove off. I drank the rest of the beers and stared out into a warm blue sky. Nellie sold almost everything on the lawn that afternoon. The only thing that was left was a torn up pillow that couldn't attract anyone's interest. I tried for a while to find the people who had bought some of Nellie's furniture and appliances. But I didn't have any luck so I'm not really sure if any of them found the cash.
内莉问了她们的地址，把床装上卡车就开车走了。我喝完了剩下的啤酒，盯着湛蓝的天空。内莉那天下午卖掉了草坪上几乎所有的东西。唯一剩下的是一个破枕头，谁也没兴趣。我试着找了那些买下内莉家具和电器的人，但我没运气，所以我不太确定他们中是否有谁发现了那些现金。
Nellie didn't have any more garage sales. He was still making money by selling ammo. And he still kept the money in those big, black garbage bags. He just stored them all in the attic where nobody ever went. And Nellie's depression didn't end. For most people, all that money would have been a sign of success. But for Nellie, it was just a bunch of paper that he couldn't get rid of.
内莉再也没举行过庭院义卖。他仍然靠卖弹药赚钱。他依然把钱放在那些大号的黑色垃圾袋里。他只是把它们存放在阁楼里，那里从来没人去。内莉的抑郁症也没好转。对大多数人来说，那些钱将是成功的标志。但对内莉来说，那只是一堆他无法摆脱的废纸。
His problem was that he liked his job. He liked the fact that he worked and that he earned a living. The part he didn't like was the actual profits. They made him feel ashamed and he had to hide them from almost everyone he knew and loved.
他的问题是他喜欢自己的工作。他喜欢自己通过工作赚钱的感觉。他不喜欢的是利润本身。这让他感到羞耻，他不得不向每一个他认识和爱的人隐瞒这些钱。
A few years later, Nellie's girlfriend left him. His kids married and moved out, and there was no one else living in his house. He started going to church to ease his depression. It wasn't really helping, he said. But he did start talking a lot about charity and how he wanted to do something good for people. And he did it in his own peculiar way. Nellie would leave a bag of money on a street corner, or late at night, he would quietly put some cash in front of a homeless person sleeping outside in the park. He would tell me that it was the only pure thing you can do on this earth. Help people without taking credit for it.
几年后，内莉的女朋友离开了他。他的孩子们结婚搬了出去，家里没别人了。他开始去教堂以减轻抑郁。他说，这并没有真正起到作用。但他确实开始多谈论慈善，谈论他想为人们做些好事。他以自己独特的方式做到了。内莉会在街角留下一个装钱的袋子，或者在深夜，静静地把一些现金放在公园里露宿的无家可归者面前。他会告诉我，这是在这个地球上你能做的唯一纯粹的事情。帮助别人却不求回报。
I know of only one person who actually found Nellie's money, my friend Darrell. Nellie had stuffed $800 into the bottom part of a toaster oven. And he left it near a dumpster where Darrell picked it up. Darrell figured some drug dealer had hidden the money there so his wife wouldn't find it, and she accidentally threw the toaster out.
我知道只有一个真正发现内莉钱的人，我的朋友达雷尔。内莉把800美元塞进了一个烤箱的底部。他把它留在了一个垃圾桶旁，达雷尔捡到了。达雷尔心想，肯定是有个毒贩把钱藏在那儿，免得他老婆发现，结果他老婆不小心把烤箱扔了。
A day before his 45th birthday, Nellie was found dead inside his house. He'd had a massive stroke. No one was quite sure exactly how long he'd been lying there. I went to his funeral. Not many people were there and I felt sad for Nellie. I hoped that maybe the homeless man who had bought the vacuum cleaner would come pay his respects. But he didn't show up. In the middle of the room there was a casket, but it was closed. Nellie's body was too decomposed for us to view.
在他45岁生日前一天，内莉被发现死在屋里。他中风了，而且很严重。没人确定他究竟在那儿躺了多久。我参加了他的葬礼。没几个人在场，我为内莉感到难过。我希望那个买了吸尘器的流浪汉能来表示敬意，但他没出现。房间中央有一口棺材，但它是关着的。内莉的尸体腐烂程度太高，我们无法瞻仰。
In the end, Nellie's family got all his money when they cleaned out his house. That's when I finally met them. They told me that they had known all along the thing that Nellie was ashamed for them to find out, how he made his money. But they could never figure out a way to tell him that it didn't matter.
最后，内莉的家人们在清理他的房子时拿走了他所有的钱。那时我终于见到了他们。他们告诉我，他们一直都知道内莉羞于让他们发现的事情，也就是他是如何赚钱的。但他们一直没能想出办法告诉他，那根本不重要。
Sudhir Alladi Venkatesh. This story is from his newest book, which comes out later this year and tells the story of the neighborhood in and around the Robert Taylor homes in Chicago. He is a professor of sociology at Columbia University and the author of Off the Books : The Underground Economy of the Urban Poor.
苏迪尔·阿拉迪·文卡泰什。这个故事出自他今年晚些时候出版的新书，书中讲述了芝加哥罗伯特·泰勒之家附近社区的故事。他是哥伦比亚大学社会学教授，也是《书外：城市贫困人口的地下经济》一书的作者。
Coming up, the celebrity who most reminds us of God and the music that we really want to hear in church as determined by scientific research. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，最让我们联想到上帝的名人，以及经科学研究确定的我们真正想在教堂听到的音乐。一会儿回来，从芝加哥公共广播电台到公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
[MUSIC - "MY IMMORTAL" BY EVANESCENCE]
[音乐 - 伊凡塞斯的《我的不朽》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Make a Better Mousetrap, we have stories of people trying to make inventions in the face of a world that does not care, does not want what they are making. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, What Would Fill-in-the-Blank Do?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“发明更好的捕鼠器”，我们有关于人们试图在面对一个并不关心、也不想要他们所造之物的世界时进行发明的故事。我们现在进行到节目的第三幕。第三幕，如果是填空题里那个人会怎么做？
Among other things, America is a place where people invent religions, the Church of Latter Day Saints, the Jehovah's Witnesses, the Church of Scientology. And then of course all kinds of very American brands of Protestantism. But despite all that, a lot of Americans still are not part of any organized religion. A 2002 USA Today Gallup poll found that 33% of Americans consider themselves quote, "spiritual, but not religious," while 10% consider themselves neither of those. That is nearly half the country.
除此之外，美国还是一个人们发明宗教的地方，耶稣基督后期圣徒教会、耶和华见证人、科学教派。当然还有各种非常美式的基督教教派。但尽管如此，许多美国人仍然不属于任何有组织的宗教。2002年《今日美国》的一项盖洛普民意调查发现，33%的美国人认为自己是“灵性但非宗教”，而10%的人认为自己两者都不是。这几乎占了全国人口的一半。
What would a church have to be to be appealing to those people? What do those people want? Well Brett Martin got the idea that somebody could actually create a religion to meet the needs of those people, a modern religion invented using the principles of modern marketing.
一个教堂要达到什么程度才能吸引这些人？这些人想要什么？布雷特·马丁认为，有人真的可以创造一种宗教来满足这些人的需求，一种利用现代营销原则发明出的现代宗教。
It used to be so easy. Back in the good old days, who cared what people wanted? If you had a new religion, you just sacked some villages, burned one or two folks for heresy and that was that. But nowadays, what with a saturated marketplace, media fragmentation and so few budgets allowing for sacking, a new faith would need much more than mere truth. It would need a clear sense of what the market demanded. It would need guidance on the most minute details, from what God looked like to what color robes the clergy would wear. In short, it would need to be focus-grouped. So that's what I set out to do.
过去这太容易了。在美好的旧时光里，谁在乎人们想要什么？如果你有个新宗教，你只要洗劫几个村庄，烧死一两个异端分子就行了。但现在，面对饱和的市场、媒体碎片化以及没多少预算支持洗劫的情况，一个新的信仰需要的不仅仅是真理。它需要明确市场需求。它需要指导方针，从上帝长什么样到神职人员穿什么颜色的长袍，细致到每一个细节。简而言之，它需要经过焦点小组测试。所以这就是我要做的事。
To guide me through the process, I turned to Paul Parton, the head of planning for the Brooklyn Brothers, a small advertising collective that's created witty campaigns for clients as diverse as CNN, Bath and Body Works and the United Nations Anti-Landmine task force.
为了引导我完成这个过程，我求助于保罗·帕顿，他是布鲁克林兄弟（Brooklyn Brothers）的规划主管，这是一家小型广告联合体，曾为CNN、Bath and Body Works和联合国反地雷特遣部队等不同客户创作过机智的广告。
At 5:00 PM on a weekday night, we gather at a facility called Focus Plus in downtown Manhattan. The offices contain three focus group rooms, each equipped with wraparound, one-way mirrors, plasma TVs and high tech audio and video recording equipment. The scene is so much like a movie version of a focus group that, watching from behind the mirror like the great and powerful Oz, I fully expect the group to burst out laughing as they file in.
平日晚上5点，我们在曼哈顿市中心一个叫Focus Plus的设施集合。办公室里有三个焦点小组房间，每个房间都配备了环绕式单向镜、等离子电视和高科技音频及视频录制设备。场景太像电影里的焦点小组了，我在镜子后面看着，像奥兹国那位伟大而强大的魔法师，我完全预期当他们走进来时小组会爆发出一阵笑声。
But these are old hands. All but one have participated in focus groups before, and Parton asks them to tick off what they discussed. "Makeup," says one. "Beer," says another. Toothpaste. IBM. Lung cancer.
但这些人都是老手了。除了一个人以外，其他人都参加过焦点小组，帕顿让他们列举一下之前讨论过的内容。“化妆品，”一个说。“啤酒，”另一个说。牙膏。IBM。肺癌。
Parton assures the group that there will be no cult recruitment following the session, that Tom Cruise is not lurking behind the mirror. Then he asks them to start talking about what they believe, 24 citizens who identified themselves as either dissatisfied with their current religion or unattached to any religion at all.
帕顿向小组保证，会议后不会进行邪教招募，汤姆·克鲁斯也不会潜伏在镜子后面。然后他让他们开始谈论自己的信仰，这24位公民都认为自己对目前的宗教不满意或根本没有宗教信仰。
Michael, a 29 year old bartender wearing a Mets jersey says, "I have this funny little thing called the tip god, where when I'm out, I tip a lot because things always come back to you." Everyone nods their heads and seems to agree that the tip god is a sound principle. Aside from this basic notion of karma though, it seems that it's hard for our panel to describe what they believe in. It's much easier to rail against what they don't believe.
迈克尔，一个穿着大都会队球衣的29岁酒保说：“我有一个有趣的小东西叫‘小费之神’，当我出门时，我会多给小费，因为事情总会回到你身边。”每个人都点头表示同意“小费之神”是一个合理的原则。不过，除了这个关于因果报应的基本概念之外，我们的成员似乎很难描述他们到底信什么。反驳他们不信什么要容易得多。
Derek, a thin, black lapsed Catholic who clearly has one or two mean nuns lurking in his past, begins to talk about the inconsistencies in the Bible. "Like, it will contradict itself one phrase after another," he says. "Yeah," chimes in Lynn, who identifies herself as a Mennonite turned Taoist. "And if you ask questions--" "--then you're going to hell," someone else finishes. Clearly, a nerve has been touched.
德里克，一个瘦小的黑人，也是个没落的天主教徒，过去显然有过一两位刻薄的修女，他开始谈论《圣经》中的矛盾之处。“比如，它会一句接着一句地自相矛盾，”他说。“是的，”琳恩随声附和，她自称是转信道教的门诺派教徒。“如果你问问题……”“……那你就要下地狱了，”另一个人补上一句。显然，触到了痛处。
Speaking of hell, the focus group tends to agree that it's a little harsh. "Burning is cruel," someone else says. They want a religion to take into account the sliding scale of sin, the fact that some transgressions are worse than others. Killing and stealing, it's generally agreed, should probably be banned. Not mixing meat and milk, avoiding meat on Fridays, facing Mecca to pray, these rules and dozens more, they say, are just too onerous and arbitrary for today's world.
说到地狱，焦点小组倾向于认为它有点太严厉了。“烧人太残忍了，”另一个人说。他们希望宗教考虑到罪恶的程度，事实是有些过错比其他的更严重。杀戮和偷窃，大家普遍认为应该被禁止。不混吃肉和奶、星期五不吃肉、祈祷时面向麦加，这些规则以及其他几十条规则，他们说，对当今世界来说太繁琐且武断了。
"The Bible says that you're not allowed to spill your seed, except for reproduction," says Micheal. "That's what it says." "And in today's modern society--" he trails off. "That's just not going to fly," finishes a  woman. After a while, the discussion has devolved into such a dorm room bull session that I'm looking around for the bong and the Georgia O'Keefe print.
“《圣经》说除了繁殖，你不准溢出种子，”迈克尔说，“它是这么说的。”“在当今现代社会……”他话没说完，“那根本行不通，”一位女士补道。过了一会儿，讨论演变成了一场宿舍里的牛皮会，我在周围找大麻烟枪和乔治亚·奥基弗的印刷画。
But Parton definitely steers the group back toward the concrete. And the consensus is simple. Just do good. Stick to the basic moral principles but streamline them. Cut out the fat. But as Parton leads the discussion, I can't help but notice that just do good is subtly shifting to just do what feels good. As the group keeps talking, it becomes clear that any new religion would have to avoid any recognizably religious traits. For instance, at one point Parton plays a selection of religious music that could be played in our new, hypothetical church. The group loves the opening bars of this--
但帕顿明确地将小组带回具体内容上。共识很简单。只要行善就行。坚持基本的道德原则，但要简化它们。剔除冗余。但当帕顿引导讨论时，我忍不住注意到“只要行善”正在微妙地转变为“只要感觉良好”。随着小组不断讨论，显而易见的是，任何新宗教都必须避免任何可识别的宗教特征。例如，帕顿播放了一段可以在我们这个虚构的新教堂里播放的宗教音乐。小组喜欢这段音乐的开头——
[MUSIC  - "HALLELUJAH" BY HANDEL]
[音乐 - 亨德尔的《哈利路亚》]
--but when it gets to this part--
但到了这一段——
[CHOIR  SINGING "HALLELUJAH]
[唱诗班演唱《哈利路亚》]
--they nearly recoil in horror. I'm sad to report that they hate this--
他们几乎惊恐地退缩了。我很遗憾地报告，他们讨厌这个——
[MUSIC  - SOUL SPIRITUAL]
[音乐 - 灵魂灵性乐]
--but like this.
但喜欢这个。
[MUSIC - NEW AGE]
[音乐 - 新世纪]
Likewise the church itself. If feeling good and doing good are one and the same in this new religion, the place of worship will have to be designed to make one feel as good as possible. They imagine an open, airy space with plenty of natural light and flowing water. There would be individual napping pods equipped with customizable music and plasma TVs showing scenes of natural beauty, like a spa. The space would be filled with warm, inviting smells. The focus group likes fabric softener and freshly baked pies. And there would also be puppies. Priests and priestesses in simple, modern robes would mingle with parishioners, look after their needs and then move on. Imagine the sales staff at Banana Republic.
教堂本身也一样。如果在这个新宗教中，感觉良好和行善是一回事，那么崇拜场所就必须设计得让人感觉尽可能舒适。他们想象着一个开放、通风的空间，有充足的自然光和流动的流水。里面会有带有可定制音乐和播放自然美景的等离子电视的个人午睡舱，就像水疗中心一样。空间里会充满温暖、迷人的气味。焦点小组喜欢织物柔软剂和现烤馅饼的味道。而且还会有小狗。穿着简约现代长袍的男女祭司会与教区居民交往，照顾他们的需求，然后离开。想象一下香蕉共和国（Banana Republic）的销售人员。
"Now, is there anything else you need to know about this new faith?" Parton asks carefully. I find myself holding my breath. This is our Emperor's New Clothes moment. I wait for the lone voice to pipe up, but what are the rituals? The rules? What do I have to do? What do you people believe? But for the first time in two hours, there was silence around the table.
“现在，关于这个新信仰，还有什么需要了解的吗？”帕顿仔细地问。我发现自己屏住了呼吸。这是我们“皇帝的新装”时刻。我等着有人冒出头来问，但仪式是什么？规则是什么？我该做什么？你们信什么？但两个小时来第一次，桌子周围一片寂静。
When asked to essentially create any theology they wanted, the universe carried on the back of a chihuahua perhaps, a female god, a turtle god, multiple robot gods, they weren't exactly interested in breaking any new ground. In the end, it seemed they wanted the new church to do more or less exactly what the old church is supposed to do, encourage good behavior, provide a sense of community and ceremony, be a place of refuge. They just wanted to be less churchy.
当被要求本质上创造任何他们想要的某种神学，比如由吉娃娃背负宇宙，女性神，乌龟神，多个机器人神，他们对打破新局面并不真正感兴趣。最终，似乎他们希望新教堂做的或多或少与旧教堂应该做的一模一样，鼓励良好的行为，提供社区感和仪式感，成为一个避难所。他们只是想让它不那么像教堂。
Now that we had the makings of our new religion, the next equally important step was how we were going to market it. Obviously, you start with a celebrity. So Parton throws the question out to the group. "Is there anybody," he asks, "who you can see endorsing a religion that you would respect?" "Bill Maher," says one man emphatically. "He doesn't believe in anything, so you know that if he's endorsing something, it's not BS."
既然我们已经有了新宗教的基础，下一步同样重要的是我们该如何营销它。显然，你要从名人开始。于是帕顿把这个问题抛给小组。“有没有谁，”他问，“你可以看到他代言一个你会尊重的宗教？”“比尔·马赫，”一个男人强调说，“他不相信任何东西，所以你知道如果他代言什么东西，那肯定不是胡扯。”
Parton shows the panel a selection of head shots. Among the rejects are Scarlett Johansson, too young. Charlton Heston, too angry. James Gandolfini, "though there's a certain roundness that I like," one woman allows. The rock, too Mayan. Brian Dennehy, blank stares.
帕顿向小组展示了一系列头像。被拒绝的有斯嘉丽·约翰逊，太年轻。查尔顿·赫斯顿，太愤怒。詹姆斯·甘多菲尼，“虽然有一种我喜欢的圆润感，”一位女士允许。巨石强森，太玛雅。布莱恩·丹内利，空白眼神。
But the overwhelming choice for the public face of our religion is someone altogether different, a man whose voice we've heard proclaiming calmly from on high so often in the movies that it's almost hard to believe that he's not up there somewhere narrating the action as we go through our daily lives. The man who reminded our group most of God himself was none other than Morgan Freeman. Wise, kindly supportive and perhaps not coincidentally, invariably a secondary character.
但作为我们宗教公众形象的压倒性选择是另一个完全不同的人，一个我们在电影里经常听到他平静地在高处宣称，以至于几乎不敢相信他不是在那儿为我们的日常生活解说的男人。那个最让我们小组联想到上帝本尊的男人正是摩根·弗里曼。睿智、亲切、支持，而且也许并非巧合的是，总是扮演配角。
Next up was developing an ad campaign. Armed with our focus group data, Parton and Brooklyn Brothers creative director Guy Barnett went to work focusing in on the anachronisms our group found in the Bible. I called it the seed spillers campaign. Here's how these ads would sound in drive time.
接下来是开发广告活动。有了我们的焦点小组数据，帕顿和布鲁克林兄弟的创意总监盖伊·巴内特开始工作，聚焦于我们小组在《圣经》中发现的时代错误。我称之为“种子溢出者”活动。这些广告在开车时的听起来会是这样。
Think about it for a second. Does God really care which way you face when you're praying? Is he really offended by the thought of a ham and cheese sandwich? Some beliefs don't make sense anymore. Some remain universal and true. Live well. Be kind. Don't kill anyone. Think about it for a second. A modern society needs a modern religion.
想一想。上帝真的在乎你祈祷时面向哪个方向吗？他真的会被火腿奶酪三明治冒犯吗？有些信仰在今天不再有意义。有些则保持普遍和真实。活得好。善待他人。不要杀人。想一想。现代社会需要一种现代宗教。
By the way, that's not actually Morgan Freeman. It's actor John Viener from The Family Guy doing an impression. Freeman, a very busy man, is off working on other projects including the sequel to Bruce Almight y, in which he plays, well, God.
顺便说一句，那其实不是摩根·弗里曼。是《恶搞之家》里的演员约翰·维纳在模仿。弗里曼是个非常忙的人，正在忙于其他项目，包括《冒牌天神》的续集，在片中他饰演，好吧，上帝。
The focus group really comes alive at these ads. "Anything that takes potshots at organized religions, I'm going to like it," one man says approvingly. Above all, it seems they're reassured by the form of these ads, by their recognizable ad-ness, that winking tone that says, you and I both know the deal here. And this makes sense. Conversion is a radical, subversive act. It helps if the evangelizing assumes a familiar form. And what could be more familiar and comforting than a man trying to sell a product? By the end of Parton's presentation, a woman named Lee says the six sweetest words a founder of a religion could ever hear, "I would totally visit that website."
焦点小组在这些广告中真的活跃起来了。“任何抨击有组织宗教的东西，我都会喜欢，”一个男人赞同地说。最重要的是，似乎他们被这些广告的形式、那种可识别的“广告感”以及那种挤眉弄眼的语气所安抚，仿佛在说：你我都懂这行当。这说得通。皈依是一个激进、颠覆性的行为。如果传教采用一种熟悉的形式会很有帮助。有什么比一个试图卖产品的人更熟悉和令人安心的呢？在帕顿的陈述结束时，一个叫李的女士说了宗教创始人能听到的六个最甜美的字：“我绝对会访问那个网站。”
At first the focus group results bothered me. These people wanted all the benefits of a faith without any of the suffering, any of the sacrifice, without believing anything. On the other hand, they invented a vision of religion that, I have absolutely no doubt, would sell. And a few weeks later I have my burning bush moment.
起初，焦点小组的结果让我很困扰。这些人想要信仰的所有好处，却不想承受任何痛苦、牺牲，也不想相信任何东西。另一方面，他们发明了一种我绝对毫无疑问会畅销的宗教远景。几周后，我有了我的“燃烧的荆棘”时刻。
I find myself, improbably, in a room with none other than Morgan Freeman himself. He's sitting across the room sagely consulting a copy of The New York Times through half-glasses. We're in a space filled with comfy chairs and soft couches. Relaxing music is playing. There is wifi access, and the aroma of warm snacks and a cool, authoritative and solicitous staff. Sunlight streams through huge windows and I can see that it is good. Here it is, I think, the scales falling from my eyes. The man in his church. We're in the first class waiting lounge at Newark Airport.
我发现自己不可思议地与摩根·弗里曼本人呆在一个房间里。他坐在房间对面，戴着半框眼镜，睿智地查阅着一份《纽约时报》。我们在一个充满舒适椅子和柔软沙发的空间里。播放着放松的音乐。有wifi接入，还有热腾腾的零食香味，以及一位冷静、权威且殷勤的员工。阳光透过巨大的窗户洒进来，我能看出这很好。这就是了，我想，鳞片从我眼中脱落。这人正身处他的教堂。我们在纽瓦克机场的头等舱候机室。
Brett Martin in New York.
布雷特·马丁，纽约。
[MUSIC - "MY GOD IS A MIGHTY MAN" BY ANTHONY BUTLER]
[音乐 - 安东尼·巴特勒的《我的上帝是位大能者》]
Act Four, Squashing the Creative Spirit. We end our program today with a tale of creativity, ingenuity, the internal striving for something better and the forces that want to stop it all at the dinner table. Andy Raskin has this story, which begins at his family's last Thanksgiving.
第四幕，压制创造精神。我们今天以一个关于创造力、独创性、内心对更美好事物的追求以及那些试图在餐桌上阻止这一切的力量的故事结束我们的节目。安迪·拉斯金讲述了这个故事，故事始于他家上一个感恩节。
I'm serving the soup.
我正在盛汤。
What story is this?
这是什么故事？
Michelle, everybody sit down please. Everybody sit down please.
米歇尔，大家都坐下。大家都坐下。
The soup story.
汤的故事。
Everyody, OK pay attention. Those that don't know the soup story have to pay attention.
大家，OK注意听。那些不知道汤的故事的人得注意听。
That's my mom, last Thanksgiving, just before she was going to tell everyone at the table, our entire family, the story about the soup that Richard, my dad, made for the meal.
那是我的妈妈，上个感恩节，就在她准备告诉餐桌上的所有人，我们整个家庭，关于我爸爸理查德为那顿饭做的汤的故事之前。
We decided that we were going to make butternut squash soup for this meal. We had made it before from a recipe in the Silver Palate Cookbook and it was very good. So I told Richard to make it. He decides that he's going to create his own version of the recipe, which I told him not to do, by the way. And I'm not going to tell you what he put in it yet, but we'll get to that as you eat it and see what's there.
我们决定为那顿饭做南瓜汤。我们以前照着《银匙厨书》的食谱做过，非常好吃。所以我告诉理查德去做。他决定要创造自己版本的食谱，顺便说一下，我告诉过他不要这样做。我还没打算告诉你们他往里放了什么，但等你们吃到它看到里面有什么的时候我们会讲到的。
I guess I'll tell you. He also decided to put in candied ginger. Out of nowhere. How do you think that that belongs in curried soup?
我想我还是告诉你们吧。他还决定放蜜饯姜。简直莫名其妙。你觉得那东西属于咖喱汤吗？
Actually, a cursory internet search yields plenty of curry recipes that call for candied ginger. But because it's so concentrated, it's usually used sparingly. My dad threw in six huge cubes. What also made my mom mad was that he substituted hot curry for mild curry, and that when he pronounced the soup done, he hadn't even tasted it.
事实上，随便查一下互联网就能搜到很多咖喱食谱需要蜜饯姜。但因为它太浓了，通常会少量使用。我爸扔了六大块进去。让我妈生气的还有，他把热咖喱换成了温和的咖喱，而且当他宣布汤做好了时，他甚至尝都没尝。
The soup was a big deal to her because they were planning to serve it in these special soup bowls. They had actually bought little pumpkin squashes and hollowed them out, one for each guest. Each one probably cost $1 or $2, but the way my mom was carrying on about them, you would think she'd she had ordered a new set of fine china to be shipped in for the occasion. I interviewed them about it.
那汤对她来说是一件大事，因为他们计划用那种特殊的汤碗来上这道汤。他们其实买了那种小南瓜并挖空了，给每个客人准备了一个。每个可能花了一两美元，但看我妈为这些碗忙碌的样子，你会以为她为这个场合订购了一套新的精美瓷器。我采访了他们。
He totally messed up the soup because he didn't listen to me. And that was a shame because now we have all these elaborate, I would say or interesting soup bowls to fill with what should be a soup commensurate with its bowl. But it's not.
他完全把汤搞砸了，因为他不听我的。这太遗憾了，因为现在我们有所有这些复杂的，我想说或者有趣的汤碗，却要装上一碗与其碗不相称的汤。但这没有。
It sounds to me that you are upset about the investment you made in the soup bowls--
听起来你是对你在汤碗上的投资感到心烦——
That's my dad.
那是我爸爸。
--and you're not even concerned about my investment of time, money and effort in creating this soup.
——你甚至不关心我在创造这道汤上投入的时间、金钱和精力。
I thought about that. But then I thought, you're the one who messed up. That's your problem. I told you to start all over again. And I thought that that would be apt punishment and maybe stop you from doing this kind of thing in the future. You see, it is salvageable to be OK, but it can never be the original recipe, which was excellent the last time we made it. So it is not going to be excellent. It may be OK. It may even be between OK and good. But it will never be excellent.
我考虑过那个。但我随后想，是你把事情搞砸了。那是你的问题。我告诉过你要从头开始。我想那会是适当的惩罚，也许能阻止你以后再做这种事。你看，它补救一下还能凑合，但它永远不可能是原始食谱，上次我们做的时候非常出色。所以它不会出色。它可能还行。它甚至可能在还可以和好之间。但它永远不会出色。
This discussion is reminiscent of the inflexibility and rigidity of your mother, which is a historical issue in this family. End of story.
这次讨论让人想起你母亲那种不灵活和刻板，这是我们家里一个历史性的问题。故事结束。
When I was growing up, my parents had this fight a million times. My dad would do something mildly inventive and then my mom would get on him for it as if he had exposed the family to life or death peril. We had a little boat and he liked to maneuver it really close into beaches so that my sister and I could go swimming and clamming. But sometimes he would run aground. And then my mom would yell at him. And her eyes would squint, and her muscles would tense up.
我成长过程中，父母为了这事吵了上百万次。我爸爸会做些稍微有创意的事，然后我妈妈就会因为这个找他麻烦，就好像他把家人置于生死攸关的危险中一样。我们有一艘小船，他喜欢把它开得离海滩很近，这样我和我姐姐就能去游泳和挖蛤蜊。但有时他会搁浅。然后我妈就会对他大吼大叫。她的眼睛会眯起来，肌肉会紧绷。
Or when my dad was driving us all in the car, he would sometimes take what he called shortcuts, which typically involved minor traffic violations. My mom would yell at him and get all squinty again, but I could see how afraid she was.
或者当爸爸开车带我们全家时，他有时会走他所谓的捷径，这通常涉及轻微的交通违法。我妈会对他大吼大叫，再次眯起眼睛，但我能看出她是多么害怕。
Watch this. Watch this.
看这个。看这个。
Wait. First taste it without the sherry because you have to compare.
等等。先在没有雪利酒的情况下尝尝，因为你得对比一下。
This Thanksgiving, in the late morning, my mom demanded that my dad throw away his soup and start over. He refused. So my mom proposed making a small batch of the original recipe and mixing that in with his version. For some reason he agreed to that, but it was still too spicy. So my dad doctored it up with even more improvised ingredients, which included apple juice, half and half, pumpkin seeds and Harvey's Bristol Cream.
这个感恩节，上午晚些时候，我妈要求我爸把汤倒掉重做。他拒绝了。于是我妈建议做一小份原始食谱，混合到他的版本里。出于某种原因，他同意了，但还是很辣。所以我爸又用更多的即兴配料改良了它，包括苹果汁、半乳半奶油、南瓜子和哈维布里斯托尔奶油。
Watch the soup come alive.
看着汤活过来。
Too much. I'll tell you something else. If he had followed the pure recipe in the book that I gave him, this would have all been unnecessary.
太多了。我再告诉你一件事。如果他按照我给他的书里的纯食谱去做，这一切都是多余的。
Finally it was dinner time and time to test the soup.
终于到了晚餐时间，是检验汤的时候了。
OK so now we've heated up the squash bowls and we're going to fill them with the quote, unquote, soup. OK, soup is on, let's go.
OK，现在我们已经加热了南瓜碗，我们要往里装那些，咳咳，汤。OK，上汤了，走吧。
My relatives, fully briefed about the controversy over the soup, had their personal squash bowls put in front of them. What were they going to say? Nobody wanted to take sides. Finally, Aunt Andrea said she liked the soup, which my dad took as a vote for him. But then she remarked that it was so spicy that he could probably sell the leftovers to an Indian restaurant. Point for mom. Uncle Robert said he liked the soup, but then we noticed the beads of sweat dripping down his forehead. All my brother-in-law would say was that the soup exceeded his expectations, which was his way of staying on good terms with both his in-laws. And me, I thought the soup had been muddied by too much compromise.
我的亲戚们已经对汤的争议进行了充分的简报，他们的私人南瓜碗摆在了面前。他们会说什么呢？没人想选边站。最后，安德里亚阿姨说她喜欢这汤，我爸把它当成了给他的投票。但随后她评论说它太辣了，他大概可以把剩下的卖给一家印度餐馆。给妈妈记上一分。罗伯特叔叔说他喜欢这汤，但随后我们注意到他额头上渗出的汗珠。我妹夫只能说这汤超出了他的预期，这是他同时与两位姻亲保持良好关系的诀窍。至于我，我觉得这汤被过多的妥协给弄浑了。
But then, a few weeks after I got home, I got an email from my mom. It was one of those lists that gets forwarded around with rules for good living, like be gentle with the earth and spend time alone every day. My mom had received it from a friend. And when she forwarded it to me, she had written on the top, "Look at number 17." It was odd because my mom doesn't usually open those kind of emails. But I skimmed down and read number 17.
但后来，我回家几周后，我收到了我妈妈的一封电子邮件。那是一份转发的清单，上面写着美好生活的规则，比如温柔对待地球，每天花点时间独处。我妈是从朋友那里收到的。当她转发给我时，她在顶部写着，“看第17条。”这很奇怪，因为我妈通常不打开那种邮件。但我扫了一眼读到了第17条。
It said exactly, "Make love and cook with abandon." When I saw that, number 17, it just flashed in my mind, oh my god this is so right. And let him be. And right then I said, you know what, why should I restrict your father's artistic pleasure in creating whatever he's creating when he cooks?
上面写着，“做爱和做饭都要随性。”当我看到那个，第17条，它突然在我脑海里闪现，天哪，这太对了。让他随性吧。就在那一刻我说，你知道吗，为什么我要限制父亲在做饭时创造任何他想创造的东西的艺术乐趣呢？
It was nice. That's about all. It was nice. It was nice that she got the message. I don't have to-- this is friends and family. I can give them a soup. If they don't eat the soup, we throw away the soup. It's not the end of the world.
那很好。也就仅此而已。那很好。她收到这条信息很好。我不必——这是亲朋好友。我可以给他们一道汤。如果他们不吃那道汤，我们就把它扔掉。这又不是世界末日。
For her I guess it was.
我想对她来说是吧。
I guess it was for her, but for me it wasn't.
我想对她来说是，但对我来说不是。
For the record, number 17 in the email my mom sent me said exactly, "Approach love and cooking with reckless abandon." How she got "make love" I'm not sure. And let's not go there. I don't know if she's really changed, if a single cheesy email could alter the way my parents relate to each other after 42 years of marriage. And my dad says that her first reflex is still to criticize him for things. But now, sometimes, he sees her catch herself and stop.
据记录，我妈发给我的邮件里的第17条准确写的是，“以鲁莽的随性来对待爱与烹饪。”我不确定她是怎么得出“做爱”的。我们还是别谈这个了。我不知道她是否真的改变了，我不知道一封庸俗的邮件能否在42年的婚姻后改变我父母相处的方式。我爸爸说她第一反应还是因为事情批评他。但现在，有时他会看到她自己克制住并停下来。
Andy Raskin in San Francisco.
安迪·拉斯金，旧金山。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help form Thea Chaloner, Sam Hallgren and Seth Lind.
我们今天的节目由莉萨·波拉克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、戴安·库克、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、艾米·奥利里和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。Thea Chaloner、Sam Hallgren和Seth Lind提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them, www.thisamericanlife.org. Or you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，您可以免费收听节目或购买CD，www.thisamericanlife.org。或者您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife从我们的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who I walked in on this week in his office.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，我这周在他办公室撞见了他。
And he's laying in the middle of the carpet, rolling around and laying around.
然后他躺在地毯中间，滚来滚去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。